[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais où la parole aux actes
antisémites sa marraine depuis cette
semaine je suis vraiment contente pour
répondre à la question de notre faire
parce que c'est une question qui êtes
vous quelqu'un c'est la question de la
lgv est une demande est ce que les
jeunes aujourd'hui peuvent utiliser
l'expression to speak to be spirituelle
pour se définir quand ils font partie de
ce qu'on peut décrire comme lgbt q2
reste plus pour dire qu'il ya une
diversité justement dans l'identité
sexuelle mais aussi dans l'orientation
sexuelle et c'est une question qui est
très sensible parce que verront les
derniers temps j'ai vu passer sur les
médias sociaux que ce soit sur titeuf ou
des fois sur instagram des vidéos de
jeunes qui déclarait ne vous appelez pas
tout se permettre
obi spirituel si vous n'êtes pas
autochtone vous n'êtes pas le droit
d'utiliser ce terme là vous ne pouvez
pas le porter et bien sûr comprendre et
c'est extrêmement compliqué comme toutes
les autres enjeux qui tourne autour de
l'identité keaton auto aussi la justice
sociale parce que malheureusement par le
passé eu beaucoup d'appellations de
description des communautés autochtones
qui ont été utilisés par des allochtone
et qui ont été déviés de leur de leur
symbolique de leur expression même du du
lien culturel communautaire historique
qui fait que ces expressions là avec
tout leur sens pour les communautés
autochtones est devenu quelque chose
d'après si paris communauté allochtone
je vais vous expliquer des fois les
hommes et les femmes médecine vont
appeler les chamans et de plus en plus
on va passer sur facebook ou même dans
les librairies délivrés par les chamanes
allochtone qui vendent le livre qui
vendre la spiritualité qui prennent des
savoirs qui ont été enseignées par les
terminaux des autochtones qui ont été
partagés que la communauté par exemple
et qui maintenant un malheureusement
sont utilisés ou plutôt sont déformés de
l'heure
lilian culturel de l'or des obligations
qu'une personne médecine pour avoir
justement de ne pas vendre la victime eh
bien ça ça fait que de plus en plus de
jeunes maintenant quand ils entendent
les personnes à l'automne s'exprimer
dire qu'ils sont tous père et le fils
spirituel
il ya une crainte que cette description
la cette autoproclamation d'être tous
péri soit accompagnée mais pas une
compréhension qui est pas du tout adapté
mais qui est vraiment basée dans le
concept à l'automne d'ailleurs les mots
plus près kobe spirituel est vraiment
une définition en français ou en anglais
pour essayer d'expliquer même le concept
qui vient avec les identités tous père
est docteur et je dis ça parce que par
le passé pour exprimer le concept
justement de bi spiritualité chez les
premières nations ont utilisé des termes
qui était très récents comme le terme
berdache par exemple certaines personnes
disent que ça aiderait le terme français
qui veut dire l'homme homosexuels soumis
dans une relation et donc vous
comprendrez que ce sont des termes qui
ont utilisé pour être expliquée à la
culture et au manque de culture
allochtone pourquoi je disais c'est
quelqu'un les premiers occupants ont
accueilli les premiers et les colons
l'existence des personnes disent que
rituel était déjà présente et d'ailleurs
elle est elle attendue à être effacées
ou grand chose à cacher ou même
rabaisser dans la mentalité des
communautés autochtones par soit les
prêtres soient les personnes qui
faisaient justement la colonisation est
une des preuves qu'on peut avoir pour
montrer que ce lien historique est très
fort or certaines photos du 19e siècle
qui existent encore qui avait été pris
par des photographes à l'octobre qui
montrait justement des personnes
biskri rituel qui était à des soins aux
femmes soit un homme parce que leur
identité et elle le prouve c'est qu'on
parle de bi spiritualité d'être tous
péri on parle encore dans une lourdeur
une banalité des identités femmes et
hommes et dans l'identité tout spirit
c'est une fluidité entre les
ce qui rend ce un peu difficile de dire
qu'elles appartiennent dans deux
polarités d'identité donc tu peux être
une femme qui aime les femmes etc senti
comme une femme tu es une femme nue dans
un corps de femme mais qui identifie
comme un homme qui continue vouloir
avoir un corps de femme mais qu'il ya
une date et qu'on peut dire plus
masculine
d'où l'idée d'avoir un peu des deux
esprits c'est aussi quelqu'un qui est né
dans le mauvais camp et qui est un homme
et qui veut vivre sa vie d'homme et vous
pour comprendre que toutes ses
différentes déclinaisons de ta position
personnelle dans ton identité et souvent
classés dans des cases de très binaire
dont une femme ont été un homme qui
s'identifie comme avec une femme mais
tel est ce bien une femme mais
finalement tu es un homosexuel parce que
tenir la corde alors congrès ces
discussions souvent auto des concepts
eurocentré d'identité et je dirais que
si on veut pour reprendre l'idée de la
vie spiritualité
l'idée de l'identité multiple de la
fluidité des gens de la fluidité aussi
des orientations sexuelles parce que tu
peux tu identifié comme un homme
hétérosexuel et avoir des relations
amoureuses homosexuels ton identité à
toi est appartient et il n'a pas besoin
de te casser dans sa conception
donc je pense que ça éviterait les gens
à temps ils veulent être identifiés
comme virtuel d'aller se renseigner sur
ce que l'habit spiritualité veut dire
d'aller enseigner aussi sur pourquoi des
réactions très fortes
ce ton autour de personnes allochtone
qui ne veulent pas comprendre les
concepts de spiritualité des personnes
autochtone qui ne veulent pas voir des
personnes allochtone prendre les thermes
ou prendre les lettres autochtones parce
qu'il ya un doute sur la raison la
motivation pourquoi on ne prend de ces
termes et aussi de se renseigner auprès
des communautés parce que chaque nation
avait des ternes certains ne savaient
même pas de thème parce que le ils ou
elles n'existaient pas dans les langues
traditionnelles autochtones par exemple
et nous on aime les femmes les hommes l
île l c'est pas dans la langue donc
quand même besoin d'eux
genre et les discussions puisque le
débat genre et c'est être plus dans des
rôles et terol était tellement larges et
variés pourrait se transformer selon les
besoins ne s'était pas classé la même
manière et je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier non plus que même la communauté
lgbt q2 s
les personnes tous spirit ont été
colonisés par des manières de penser et
on est en processus de décolonisation
dont il faut pas oublier que certaines
personnes autochtones des colonies
semelle elles mêmes leurs savoirs de ce
qu'est l'identité tout spirit doivent
enlever certains des enseignements très
moisis est très lourd et très dur a
enlevé parce que répéter et répéter
répéter souvent et donc en colonisant
même nom concept qu'on ait eue par
l'éducation et en reprenant certains des
ternes en partageant aussi
l'enseignement qui existent un peu
partout sur justement didonne étaient
tous péri on apprend donc si on veut
utiliser le terme de spiritualité se
renseigner auprès de personnes y sont
inscrites ul et se dire que il faut
avoir une bonne compréhension 6-2 d'où
ça vient cette description là et que
même au coeur des communautés qu'on dit
mgb des guides us
il reste quand même des modèles
d'oppression auprès de certaines
personnes de la communauté
donc même nous dans nos gros dans deux
classes qu'elles soient autochtones
qu'elle soit de la famille justement
tous péri il y a aussi des processus de
guérison qui sont en cours et ne pas
oublier mais c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut que réapparaisse dans la culture
qu'il faut qu'il soit partagé parce que
pourquoi se limiter l'esprit quand on
peut ouvrir justement les portes de
notre tête et les portes de notre carte
alors je souhaite une belle semaine
merci beaucoup david pour ta question il
s'était pas partager cette vidéo
et surtout n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner encore plus sur le sujet